[Music]  this is conan and plum  two very still new caledonian geckos  found exclusively in the territory of  new caledonia these geckos can be  spotted on the southern portion of the  island  they have been known to grow up to 14  inches in length  while that may not seem very big conan  and plum are the largest living species  of gecko in the world  typically very calm they only move when  absolutely necessary  [Music]  a greenish mossy pattern coats their  body camouflaging them in their natural  habitat  their colours range from a rusty red and  brown to green or grey  unlike most geckos it has claws on its  toes and these along with a grasping pad  under the tail help it cling to tree  trunks  the primary threat to this species is  the continued loss and degradation of  forest habitat  this is the new caledonian gecko  [Music]  you